Hello,
you sexy people out there.
This is Tim Ferriss and this episode
of the Tim Ferriss podcast has a very
special guest,
Josh Waitzkin,
whom I met in 2007 after reading his
spectacular book, the art of learning.
Josh, you may know from
searching for Bobby Fisher,
he was the subject of both the book and
the movie he's thought of as a chess
prodigy.
Although that term prodigy I don't believe
applies to him well at all because he
has a method for learning,
mastering, refining any skill,
whether that is chess,
whether that is Tai Chi in which he's
multiple time world champion Brazilian
Jujitsu in which he's a
black belt under the phenom,
the Michael Jordan of the sport Marcella
Garcia and he's worked with people
ranging from mark [inaudible] six time
Stanley Cup winner to cal Ripken Jr to
the top hedge fund managers in the world.
He is a performance specialist and also
very dear friend of mine now at this
point and I ended up loving his book,
the art of learning so much that I
acquired the rights to his audio book.
If you want to find that it's read by
Josh himself and a you can just go to for
our blog for h o U R B l o g.com and
search for Tim Ferriss book club or go to
Google and do the same.
So without further ado,
let's get straight to the meat of
the interview. I hope you enjoy it.
Optimal.
And then
my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
So Josh,
I figured we might as well start
at the top and do a little retrospective.
What led you initially to
write the art of learning?
And of course that's how I was in many
ways introduced to your work and then
through our mutual friend Max ended
up connecting. But what was the,
what was the reason you
decided to write that book?
Um,
so I transitioned into meditating and
just studying East Asian philosophy and
then I started getting into each
one and ultimately into the Marshall
application of it,
pushed him and I started to experience
this very interesting transition from,
from the principals my level.
And Chester's began to translate
directly over into the martial arts.
And I think, I think it was
primarily one experience I had,
but it was something around two
years into my tattoo training,
I was giving a simultaneous
chest exhibition in Memphis,
Tennessee at a fundraiser razor for
muscular dystrophy and I was playing 45 or
50 boards at once.
I was at someone walking down the
middle of this big square of chess.
Paypal's everyone's playing one game.
I'm playing each of them and about
40 minutes into the Simon I had this
experience that was so interesting.
I began to feel like I was riding
the energetic wave of the game.
Like I was in my push hands training.
I wasn't playing chess,
I wasn't thinking in chest language,
I wasn't calculating variations.
I was feeling the flow,
filling the space behind,
like they wouldn't have martial arts.
And I had this realization, you know,
I was playing beautiful chess,
but I wasn't consciously playing chess.
But the barriers between these two
different or to dissolve in my mind and
that's when I started to conceive of
the idea of the book and a lot of the
process of I spent five
years taking notes, me four,
500 pages of notes in the book before
I actually sat down and wrote it.
And a lot of that process was
deconstructing what I'd been doing rather
intuitively.
Um,
so essentially what it felt like before
his translation of parallel learning.
These are two rather abstract terms of
that's the language that I was using
internally when I was first thinking
about the book because it felt like I was
just taking the essence of one art
and translate it over into another.
And in the process of writing it involved,
deconstructing what I'd been doing, um,
somewhat abstractly and is something that
can be replicated more systematically.
Simon,
you 10,
20, 30, 40 boards simultaneously.
I'll try to ask a better question then.
How does someone do that?
But at what point,
what happens to a chess player when they
go from an inability to play multiple
boards simultaneously to being able to
play multiple boards simultaneously?
What is the sort of
framework or thinking or, or,
or experience and so in bolts up that
allows them to do something like that,
which to the average person
seems like a rain man, like feet
know. I think it's different
for every chess player. I mean,
one of the beautiful things about chess
is that you can approach it so many
different ways and to be world class,
what you need to do essentially
is expressed the core of
your being through the
art.
I think that's just,
this is true of many arts
and that's probably something
that we'll get into more
deeply. Um, so you can have a very
mathematical person who plays chess.
Mathematically, you can have a very
musical person who plays chess music.
Someone might be much more kinesthetic
like myself and sort of a feeling for
flow and hidden harmonies and,
and almost a physically energetic
relationship to chest. Um,
when I first learned to play chess when
I was six years old in Washington square
park, it was, it was a battle.
I love the feeling of, of the,
of just going to into a fight with
someone and finding these hidden harmonies
and finding where these animal pet
passions and mixed with this technical
complexity.
And when I get late much later when
I got much better playing Simos um,
it was sort of a higher
level manifestation of
that same kind of dynamic.
I mean for me playing Simos was something
akin to juggling a lot of balls and,
and all of the, to each chest. I wasn't
playing 40 different games for example,
separately,
the flow of all 40 games would sort of
coalesce into one larger sense of flow.
And it was actually really
interesting whenever,
as often when I give a Simon and there'd
be a youth competition and the winners
of the youth competition
would play against me.
And so sometimes kids would would cheats,
they'd really want to be and
these two they would sheets. I've,
you're walking around this big thing.
And then I get to the table and it
shifted the position to try to win because
they're getting when it
would be a big thing.
And my experience when that
happened was as if you had,
imagine you would like 40 balls up in
the air and suddenly then it all crashed
into the floor. And I would know
that they had changed the position,
not by reaching the board and remembering
what the position was and then seeing
they changed it.
It would initially be this feeling of
the energetic flow has been interrupted.
Um, and then I'd have to reverse engineer
myself back to that one, what one game,
that one component of the flow.
And then I remember the game and then I
would remember exactly division had been,
and then I'd say that
this was the position. Um,
and then would take me two or three
times going back around and they get that
all the balls back up in the air and
they get back to the energetic flow.
So actually for me,
giving Simos sort of felt similar
to playing chess one Cheskin. Um,
but that was my own relationship to it.
I think that probably if
you're adding 10 different,
very strong chess players that all
give somewhat different answers.
Spending time with a friend of yours
when we went to Washington square park
and seeing him play game at least for the
first portion without
looking at the board.
And I'm not gonna I won't
give away too much of the two.
Most of the punch lines since we,
uh, we captured it all on a film.
It was pretty amazing.
But just his ability to track the board,
uh,
it seemed like by chunking portions
of the board into sort of larger,
um, like distal pieces. I, I don't know
if that's the best way to express it,
but it seemed like his
ability to seemingly remember
all these disparate pieces
was because he had it broken,
the,
the board broken down into sort
of a component chunks as it were.
But, uh, I don't want to take us
to down that, that fine line. Um,
let's, let's shift gears. I want to,
what I'd be very curious to know is, um,
you know, at this point what, what,
because I know of course a little
bit of the background, but, uh,
I want to dig into the details.
What type of people do you personally
work with these days and why do they work
with you?
What type of things do you do with them?
Yeah,
three major dimensions
to my creative life.
I guess the most important
one is my son Jack,
who I use it a little over two
years old and loving my life.
So that's maybe the most important part
of my life. No question about it. Um,
I run a nonprofit educational
foundation and we have, um,
a couple of JW foundation and
the art of learning projects. Um,
and we have a couple of hundred programs
in schools around the country and
internationally as well.
And so this is integrating
these principles that have
been developing in, in,
in schools,
working with teachers,
parents and children around
this individualized and
automatic relationship to
learning and development.
So this is one dimension.
The other one is I own
a martial arts school.
Of Brazilian Jujitsu to school with um,
Marcello Garcia,
who's the nine time world
champion. You know, I'm well Tim,
he's just make really the Michael
Jordan of the grappling world. Um,
so there's this world class athletes
training there and then I run a consulting
business where I'm training people who
are at the cutting edge of the finance
world.
And this is really interesting work
cause we're focusing on that last one or
0.1% of the learning process,
which is really my specialty.
It's highly individualized,
this cutting edge work on their learning
process that their idea generation,
their creativity, that performance
psychology, their resilience. Um,
fascinating work. And you know what I
discovered, it's interesting because I,
I wrote this book called
the art of learning years
ago and so people are always
coming to me to speak about learning,
but much of what I've been focused on
in recent years has been learning when I
think, when I think about that
last, that last movement, you know,
from the equivalent of being say
number 10 to number one in the world.
And number five being
number one in the world.
It's much more about finding subtle
obstructions, finding friction points,
releasing, um, identify and cognitive
biases and make blocking your way.
It's sort of, it's the movement
towards unobstructed self expressions.
Every think about about your
creative process as a hose with a,
with a big crimp in it.
If you're released it just unbelievable
pressure can be released. Um,
and a lot of what I'm doing with
people is trying to move them from,
from very good to great or
from great to truly elite, um,
just deeply individualized
work and helping them really
find ways to express the
core of their being through
their art, which is, as you know,
a big theme in my life from when I
played chess at my highest level.
That's what I was doing when I had a
period of being really locked up in my
check his career, which we can go
into in more detail if you want.
I was doing the opposite. I was trying
to fit into someone else's mold.
And then ultimately when I transitioned
away from Chason to the martial arts,
I returned to that experience of,
of self expression.
And that's what I really start
to understand it very deeply.
I think it was the crisis towards
the end of my chess career,
which really literally the foundation
for the work that I used today with,
with brilliant mental performance who
are just trying to make that movement to
the equivalent to a world champion.
Yeah.
And you've, you've gone to war
with him and I've watched you,
I've gone to war with him,
which I, if there's anything
at stake, I don't recommend
you guys got to be a lot of pain.
He's a tough guy,
but also a sweetheart of a guy and
he's so fluid. Uh, what I'd love to hear
from you, of course, because in the,
the, in the art of learning, which,
which some people might be familiar
with the read about your experiences and
chest,
your experiences in Tai-chi,
the parallels between them and this
sort of over arching a framework for
optimizing mental and physical
performance, if that's a
fair way to put it. Uh,
which is, you know, the, the,
the art of learning these different
techniques and strategies. What,
what have you learned through this
third art or Brazilian Jujitsu?
What are,
what are some insights or strategies that
you've had since moving from Tai Chi,
which is in some ways similar but also
very different from Brazilian Jujitsu,
which a lot of people would be familiar
with through the UFC and mixed martial
arts
learning ends with the 2004 world
championship. It ends with it.
It was just absolutely
hiring crazy experience. Um,
I won't give the punchline but,
but it was, it was really intense.
And after this I just started,
I decided I wanted to be a beginner,
getting to put on a white belt,
um, literally and figuratively.
And so I took on this third major mountain
in my life, preserving, you should sue.
I was training out in the west coast
for about a year when I was actually
writing the art of learning.
I was training Brazilian Jiu Jitsu twice,
a twice a day. Um, this was after
I'd spent five years taking notes.
Then I had the 2004 worlds
when I was writing it. Um,
I started training with John Machado
out there. Then I came back to New York.
I started training with
Marco Austin does here,
and I started to develop this
relationship with Marcello,
who's just the greatest
grappler to ever live.
And we were doing a lot of
private lessons. Um, I was,
we developed a friendship,
then he moved to Florida and I would
travel to Florida to work with him.
And ultimately I made the decision,
I wanted to bring him to
New York mostly because I,
I was at that point planning to make a
run for the world championship and this
art and there was no better way to do
it then to get my ass kicked by the very
best to ever live in the sport.
And he's just a wonderful guy. Um,
and he's just unbelievable
martial artists.
And so we opened up the school together
and [inaudible] I've been on the mass
with him,
you know,
other than when one of us has been
injured and it's been a lot of injuries in
these sports just all the time.
And it's been a fascinating experience
and more solar was so profoundly
different from me. I'm a really
conceptual guidance. I think abstractly,
of course my foundation and chest
Marcello is one of the most,
well he's the most kinesthetically
overdeveloped person they've ever met.
And of course over development under
development tend to come hand in hand
conceptually.
Um,
an example of that would be an example
of overdevelopment own development,
uh, of kinesthetic. What it
means to be kinesthetically
his physical intelligence
is mind boggling.
And then when he'd come fishing with me,
you know,
you throw him on a standup paddleboard
in three foot shop and everyone just
flies off of paddle boards and they
should just stand up on them and he's just
beautiful. I'm just, you just find the
balance points I've never seen one soon.
Someone learn so quickly how to handle um,
waves,
boats, handling, fishing lines
being, you know, free diving,
being on riding waves on paddle
boards. You know, when you,
when you're in the marsh. I've been
a stand up fighter for many years.
I mean throwing as my core, my core when
I'm doing standup training with Marcel,
I caught him with most of the
throws of my repertoire one time.
I don't think I've ever caught
him with a throw twice. Wow.
As you were world class while
I was training with, you know,
I catch them thousands of times.
This is a guy, he, he just,
you almost never see Marcello get
caught more than once with something.
Um,
and it's amazing to see how he relates
to the world through is kinesthetic
intelligence. So for
example, if you're looking,
when we were looking for
spaces for our school,
we'd walk into a big room and I be
thinking about the dimensions, you know,
the square footage where this would be,
where that would be more so it would
know if it felt good or felt bad.
If he meets you,
he's going to know whether he feels good
about you or he feels bad about you and
his intuition is incredibly dead on.
But he navigates the world through
this Kenneth Static intelligence.
And it's been a really fascinating having
the school with him and diving deep
with them.
Um,
because we've been having
conceptual dialogue these
three and a half years or so,
and he's really deepened,
um, conceptually,
but I've learned even more deeply in the
importance of the lesson that there are
many paths to greatness.
And to take a guy like Marcello and to
try to fit them into a chess players,
you know,
hyper conceptual molds would be terrible
because you'd be killing is shine.
And he is so great because of his just
unbelievable commitment to doing it his
way. And he's done things in
extraordinary ways. I mean, for example,
you know how in these competitive arts,
everyone's very secret about
the repertoires. Yep. Um,
well we have this program which you know
well called Mgu inaction where people,
just two guys from around the world log
in to watch all of our sorrows training
sessions, his sparring
sessions, his lessons,
everything when he was competing
it not with Dobie submission,
grappling world championship.
And when jobs,
which is the Brazilian Jujitsu
world championship, we were spoiled.
We were streaming is sparring
sessions every night.
So he was basically showing
these competitors what he
was about to two weeks.
In three weeks, four weeks.
And his attitude about this,
which is completely unique,
if you're studying my game,
you're entering my game and
I'll be better at it, you know?
Yeah.
I'm the opposite of what most chess
players would do and most of your district
guys would do. And so he's wide open
to constant learning and they look at,
the beautiful thing about Marcello is,
you know,
if people call him the king of scrambles
and if you watch his training style,
he's always in transition,
which is a really interesting idea to
think about in a cross disciplinary manner
because most people get
their egos involved in their
training and they're trying
to dominate all the time and to dominate.
And almost anything you find a
position of dominance and you keep it.
But Marcello always led
to the opponent's move.
And so he's constantly
playing in transition.
And so if you think about what worldclass
martial arts means, and you brought up,
for example, Merissa Ashley and it
playing chess and Washington square,
it's similar. If you're at a
much higher level than someone,
you can always seem mystical because
you're things which are outside of their
conceptual scheme.
The way that operates in the martial
arts is if you think about it through the
lens of frames,
right?
If you and I are looking at a position
and in your mind there's this position,
this position, this position. Um, so
there's three positions in my mind.
If I'm constantly training at the
transitions between these petitions,
these actually expand in
these transitional frames
become positions to me.
And so if I'm seeing a hundred
positions when you're seeing take two,
then I can play in your blind spots and
they could see mystical to you because
you haven't trained there.
And that's what Marcella does,
like spending all of
his time in transition.
He's cultivated the art to play in the,
in between,
which is really what level is all about.
Um,
or one of the core things that highlight
the worldclass martial arts is all
about playing in transition and
gaps in your opponents. Syep pattern
just blew me away because if you look
at it as an uninformed spectator or even
just a moderately informed spectator,
you're blown away by how fast he is,
how effectively he is.
But the,
the nuance of sort of eliciting movement,
allowing space to open
manufacturing space by let's say,
applying pressure and then leaving it is
so subtle and so incredibly effective.
I mean,
then you start to notice it from these,
these principles of carry over to
many, many hundreds of possible, uh,
positions. Let's just say. Um, it's
really, yeah, it's really amazing. I mean,
it reminds me of something I heard
once from a musician, which was, uh,
I don't know who the original quote
is from, but he said that, you know,
music is the space between the
notes. And I was like, Huh,
that's a really interesting way
to look at it. Uh, but, but,
but what were you gonna say?
I think that's just a gorgeous quote and
I think that that are defined by that,
that space in between.
Yeah. Well, it's like writing, writing
is the same way, right? It's like,
when in doubt, leave it out. It's
just like, you know, it's uh, I think,
uh,
yeah.
Beautiful, beautiful plan.
Yeah, of course. It's,
think about Marcello is that it can
often seem initially that he's moving so
fast,
but what's incredible is that he can also
move very slow and do things that you
don't see.
I'm just like a great side of sleight
of hand artist who's just practicing the
art of illusion when
we're not practicing it.
It's amazing what can
be done with intention,
with controlling someone's intention.
Um,
and this is a lot of my training and
push hands related to finding ways to,
to essentially control someone's intention
so that you were ahead of them even
if, if they were ultimately
moving first. Um,
you were there before they
arrived. This is fascinating. Um,
psychological component of really
high level training in anything.
Well, I, uh, I remember an
interview or it wasn't an interview,
a window wasn't interview actually with,
um,
one of the top k one fighters
back in the day. Yeah. Uh,
and they were talking about Peter air,
et cetera.
If you remember the Dutch lumberjack,
huge guy and he,
he seemed fast.
And I remember what people said.
A number of opponents said, you know,
he's, he's actually not that fast.
He's kind of a big lumbering guy,
but he's so good at predicting timing
that he sees you telegraph before you even
have the thought to throw the Punch and
he beats you to the punch as a result of
that. But it's because he's, he picks
up on the cues faster than other people.
And I thought that was
very interesting to, uh,
to try to bridge this to something else.
I mean, what you work with, of course,
I'm not gonna mention names,
but you work with some of the
most stunningly successful
and famous traders and
people in finance. I mean some real kind
of masters of the universe type folks.
What,
what have you,
what have you found unique
about that group of people?
Uh, let's, let's, let's
just start with that. Um,
I'm curious to know kind of what you've,
what you've noticed being as observant
as you are about that group of folks.
Oh,
that's a big question.
It is a big question.
I mean,
each one of these guys who's really
world class is doing it his way and he's
harnessing that
he's cultivating or his or her
strengths as a way of life. Um,
there's not an excessive focus on
weakness. There's just an embracing of
deep,
deep study of the preconditions to
someone's finest moments of expression and
building lifestyle surrounded.
And that's a lot of what I do is help
people understand what makes them tick on
a very, very deep level
relative to, um, you know,
the cognitive biases where they locked
up and were there reasons has become, um,
what kind of external conditions,
what kind of internal conditions.
And the ones who were really
at the top are people who,
who have mastered this art
of deep introspection and
taking the result of these
interspective processes and turn them
into training systems and into a way of
life. Um, and it's fascinating how, how,
how the process works. And what
I do with these guys is I, I, um,
if after I do my initial
diagnostic process,
I have ways of revamping
of the daily architecture,
the way they live their life
so that they're, for example,
aligning their peak energy periods
where there be creativity work.
They're building lifestyles that
are just relentlessly proactive,
um, as opposed to reacting to inputs.
They're building a daily architecture,
which is based on maximizing
the creative process.
And if you think about this
relative to most people, um,
simple case in point is email checking,
right?
And most people when they finish a break,
even, even top guys and industries,
when they finish a break, whether they
wake up first thing in the morning,
what do most people do?
They check their email when
they come back from a workout,
whether they check their email,
when they come back from lunch ways,
do they check their email?
And so what you see is this,
whenever they're coming back from
something after a break there soaking in
inputs. And so they live this
reactive lifestyle there.
Their creative process is dominated by
external noise as opposed to internal
music.
Um,
and a lot of what I work on with guys
is creating rhythms and their life that
really are based on feeding the
unconscious mind, which is really,
which is the wellspring of
creativity information. Um,
and then tapping it.
So for example,
ending the workday with high quality focus
on a certain area of complexity where
you could use an insight and then waking
up first thing in the morning pre input
and applying your mind to
it. Journaling on it. Um,
not so much to do a big brainstorm
but to tap what you've been working on
unconsciously overnight,
which of course is a principle
the Hemingway wrote about
when he spoke about the
two core principles in his
creative writing process
where one ending the workday
with something left to right.
Yup.
Right.
So not doing everything he had to do,
which most people do because they feel
the sense of guilt if they're not working.
Um,
you and I have discussed this at length,
but leaving something left to right
and then waking up and then the second
principle, release your mind from
it. Don't think about it all night.
Really let go. Have a glass of wine
and wake up first thing in the morning,
then reapply your mind to it.
And it's amazing because you're basically
feeding the mind complexity and then
tapping that complexity our top
and what you've done with it.
And I mean this rhythm,
you know, the, the,
the large variation of it is overnight.
Then you can do micro bursts of it
throughout the day before workouts.
Pose a question and do a workout, release
your mind after workout, return to it,
and do a creative burst before you go
to the bathroom, before you go to lunch,
before anything.
And there's a way of systematically
training yourself to generate the
crystallization experienced ah ha moment.
That can happen once a
month or once a year.
A lot of what I do is work on systems to
help it happen once a day or four times
a day.
Um,
and when you're talking about guys who
run by answer groups of 20 to $30 billion,
for example,
if they have a huge insight that can,
that can have unbelievable value.
And so if you can really train people
to get systematic about nurture in their
creative process,
it's unbelievable what can happen.
And most of that work relates
to getting out of your own way.
At a very high level. It's,
it's unlearning, it's the
constant practice of sure.
Subtraction, reducing friction. Um,
you mentioned cognitive people who
may not be familiar with that term,
cognitive biases and how
someone might work on them,
right? Well, there are a lot
of cognitive biases that are,
that are specific to certain disciplines
like chess or finance or philosophy.
Um, but if we just think about
it in terms of everyday life, um,
let's say we make a decision and we then
feel the need to justify that decision.
And so we make more decisions to
justify that Mitchell decision.
And then we basically get
herself into this deep wormhole,
which is caused by the attempt to justify.
Exactly.
So this is in the financial group who
were one of the world's talking about sunk
cost fallacy, right? Um, but this is
very interesting for, for example,
a chess player who makes a
certain decision and there's
a certain emotional and
intellectual and time component to the
value we put into the thought process
behind that decision. And what we often
have to do is release it because the, the,
the position changes shape.
A very interesting way that
this manifests in chest,
which you can think
about rather universally,
is let's say that there is a certain
evaluation to the position, right?
You and I are playing,
Tim and I have a slight advantage in
the position that I'm nurturing that
advantage of nurturing
them nurturing and um,
and a lot of complexity and make a spider.
And suddenly the addition is equalized,
right?
So if I'm holding on to the past
evaluation emotionally where I had the
advantage,
then what I'm going to do very subtly
is I'm going to reject positions that
don't give me that advantage.
But if that I no longer have an advantage
that I'm going to be reaching too far,
right? Um, and then I'm only
rejecting things they should accept,
which will make my position to
slip more and more and more.
And you fall into what I call it,
downward spiral.
So this relates to a lack of presence,
which really connects to a cognitive bias
and addiction to a past evaluation as
opposed to a present one. Um, so
that's a very simple example of,
of a cognitive bias.
Um, a mental addiction,
I thought constructs something that we
hold to be true because of some comp
complicated twist in our mind.
It's no longer actually true.
And so of course a very simple antidotes,
motion, most of us is presence.
If we can look at a moment or chest
position or an investment decision or any
decision with very clean presence
outside of kind of emotional inertia,
um,
then we can often slice through just
amazing amounts of fat with just very,
very simple decisions. If you think
about the learning process, for example,
and this is one thing that I love
about your approach to learning,
I language that you and I
use is, you know, I call you
a master of deconstruction.
You look at the way people approach
different sports and you find the biases,
the false construct,
right?
And you find a way to learn
a very straight path to learning as
opposed to people getting mired and all
sorts of tangled webs of complexity,
which, which are, you know,
essentially caused by cognitive biases,
wouldn't, isn't how you'd put it.
I think you and I have very complimentary
approaches and like you've said before,
and I tend to focus on
the 80 20 analysis as it,
as it applies to people getting up and
off the ground as quickly as possible to
say, you know, top whatever, five
to 10% in the general population.
Whereas what's so cool about
our conversations would I
enjoy so much in part is
that, you know, you're really focusing
on that, that, that final leap.
How do you go from being great
to being the best? Right?
And they're, they're very,
they're, they're very complimentary
skill sets. I think that, uh,
yeah, but when I'm looking
at, and this is a, is a,
is a way to unearth cognitive biases.
And just as a side note for
people who want to look into this,
you can just go to Wikipedia and search
list of cognitive biases and there's,
there's a long list which is
pretty fun to read. Um, and, uh,
there are a number of books about these
types of things to think twice I think
is another one. Um, the, the
question that I ask myself,
and I'm always interested in the questions
that people ask themselves because I
find it in to my mind that those,
that internal dialog is what defines your
day to day thinking and what you think
you become. So it's so critical that
you ask yourself the right questions.
And in my mind what, or I
should say, rather, when I'm
trying to deconstruct, say,
a sport, all I'll ask it is
to start with, you know, what,
what rules are people following
that are not required?
Right? So, you know, outside
of the law and science, uh,
and even within science and within law,
reality's gonna negotiable. So I mean,
a good instance, a of that
is the high jump and, uh,
the Fosbury flop.
So Dick Fosbury and it was really the
first guy to go backwards over the high
joke and up to that point there had
been straddled kicks and all sorts of
different approaches and he was ridiculed
at first and then he was called a
cheat because he won the gold medal. And
now everybody uses that approach. And uh,
so you know, having, uh, a list of
questions, right, who's good at this,
who shouldn't be is another one that
I love to ask because you might find
someone,
for instance,
you were talking about the
different styles and in
chess or Jujitsu or in chess,
you know,
as sort of a reference to
your first book, uh, you know,
you have attacking chessplayers,
right? Then you have,
you have very different stylistic
differences and you've very quantitative
players. Uh, and for the, for the, the
TV show for the Tim Ferriss experiment,
I did an episode on poker and I've avoided
poker my whole life because of viewed
it as a game of chance. And I had a, a
former computer science guy who said, no,
no,
I'm not going to teach you to be lucky
because I can't teach you to be lucky. Uh,
but I can teach you to run
some probabilities and only
bet when you have a good
likelihood of a positive,
a positive outcome. Right?
And what what was so fascinating is you
look at a guy like that and you'll find
a highly quantitative, say,
Hedge Fund managers for instance,
or a or investors of different types,
tech investors who,
who go to the world series of
poker and they run the numbers.
That's how they play.
And then there are other guys who were
completely seemingly flying by the seat
of their pants. I mean,
they're very kinesthetic.
They're playing intimidation
game. They're very physical. Um,
and, uh, so asking myself, for instance,
who's good at this? Who shouldn't be,
if the assumption is you have to be very
good at math to be good at poker, right?
Who, who admits to using no math,
which might be misinformation, but,
and let me look into how they do it.
And then the second question is,
you have they replicated their results?
Are there other people they've taught to
do what they do to try to separate out
the, the nature from the
nurture where possible. But, uh,
I want to come back to, you know, the,
the finance guys just for a second and
to ask you about a rituals and routines
and I'm going to ask you about your
own, but what are some habits, uh,
and it doesn't have to be across the board
with all these guys because they have
such different personalities
and approaches, but with
some of these, uh, you know,
really super high level finance guys
who are managing tens of billions of
dollars,
what are some of the habits that you've
observed that you find interesting? Uh,
or rituals?
Let me answer that by describing some of
the keystone habits that I recommend
for people to internalize it and in the
field.
Um,
what will mean first of all,
meditation. I mean we're,
we're speaking about this
theme of cognitive biases or,
or find it basically observing your mental
dictions the moment that they said in
meditation is as deep and
as powerful a tool as, um,
as I could possibly describe.
I mean, it's, it's an,
and maybe six or seven years ago when I
was first talking about meditation with
guys and the finance world,
it seemed like some woo,
strange thing for them to take on.
Um,
but as more and more people are
integrating into the process, I mean,
you wouldn't believe how many of the
most powerful players in the world are
meditating very deeply. Um, it's
just an amazing way of deepening, um,
deep into the creative process,
deepening presence, um,
expanding your energetic relationship
to the world, gaining insight, um,
and realizing that most of the thinking
that we do basically springs from mental
addiction and much of people's lives
are spent in an emotional swirl,
which is a reactive one.
And having a relationships presidents,
which allows you to see through the kind
of illusion of that emotional swirl or
those mental addictions.
I mean, meditation is an
incredibly powerful tools.
I know, you know, like deeply, I've been
meditating since I was 1718 years old.
You know, it's a big part of your
life as well, Tim. So that's a very,
very important habit.
The idea of waking up first thing in
the morning and turning your mind to
creative work, pre input as opposed to
checking email and getting reactive.
Um, opening up your channel
to the unconscious mind first.
Then when you wake up in
the morning doing the same,
ending the workday with
quality, hugely important. Uh,
I remember why I went skiing with Billy
Kidd, who is my recall at one of them,
the Great Danielle ratios from back in
the think the sixties Olympic ski team.
Awesome dude. Now he's, he's
out in Colorado wearing a
cowboy hat. Timeless guy.
Brilliant Dude.
And you know,
he was saying to me years ago when
I first skied with them, Josh,
what do you think of the three most
important terms of the ski run?
And you know I've asked that question
to a lot of people since and most people
will say the middle
cause it's the hardest,
the beginning cause they're getting
momentum really describes the three most
important terms of the ski run in the
last three before you got in the lift.
And it's a very, very subtle point. And
it, for those of you who are skiers,
you know that you know,
that's when the slope is leveled off.
There's less challenge.
Most people are very sloppy.
Then they're taking the mussels off of um,
they're taking the weight off the muscles.
They've been using that bad form.
Problem with that is
that on the lift ride up,
unconsciously you're internalizing and
bad body mechanics. As Billy points out,
if you were here, last returns are
precise than what you're internalizing.
Lift right up his precision. So I
kind of did this on to, you know,
the guys who are trained in
the finance world, for example,
ending the workday with very high quality,
which opens up for one thing.
You're,
you're internalizing quality overnight
and were nurturing themes as well as
skills, right? It's one
thing to learn skills,
but the hire artists to learn themes or,
or Meta themes that will
ultimately spontaneously
opens to the amendment to the
internalization of hundreds of, of
what I would call local habits. Um,
and, and so if you're practicing
quorum or the, you're,
you're deepening the muscle of quality
and you're also focusing the unconscious
mind them and Eric complexity, which
will then tap first thing in the morning.
So this is a core habit.
Um,
journaling certain postmortem
procesees is reflecting on the,
you know, doing the ending your day with
a reflection on the quality of the work.
Um, what are the core areas of complexity
that you're, that you're wrestling with?
Um, hugely important. You know,
if
someone
I time at the end of the workday before
the problem with doing these things and
right before bed is it,
then you're sort of consciously going
to bed thinking about these things.
At that point, I find you want to release
it. So I'm in a very core idea is,
you know, when you go home as best you
can, unless you're red hot inspired,
release your mind from the work.
Um,
it's very important to give your stress
and recovery. Um, core habit, right?
We want to be turning it on and turning
it off and keep and teaching people
people to turning it off is a huge part
of teaching them to turn on much more
intensely.
And so stress and recovery workouts,
interval training and meditation together,
our beautiful habits to develop,
to cultivate the art of turning
it on and turning it off.
So if you're undulating your heart
rate, for example, between one 71 72,
one 74 and say one 40 for the practice
of lowering your heart rate over the
course of say,
45 seconds is akin to falling asleep,
releasing your tension. Um, and then as
you're pushing your heart rate back up,
you're learning and turn it on is you're
using a physical metaphor to train at
the art of turning on
incredible intellectual and
then turn it off Marcel with,
see if we were talking about one of my
most beautiful memories of him and you
know, world championship fight
before going into the semifinals.
Bronchus bleacher, everyone's
screaming, yell, and he's sleeping,
sleep,
wake them up.
He sort of stumbled into the ring.
You've never seen a guy more relaxed
before going into a world championship
fight. Um, and then he can turn it off so
deeply in man, when he goes in the ring,
you can't turn on with any
more intensity than he can.
And his ability to turn it off is directly
aligned with how intensely you can
turn it on.
So training people to do this,
have stress and recovery
undulation throughout their
day. Um, and then, you know,
thematically this ties into
again, this internal, um,
proactive orientation and you know,
building a daily architecture,
which is around understanding your
creative process as opposed to reacting to
things,
feeling guilty that you're not working,
really teaching people to tap
into their internal compass. Um,
so those are some of the core
themes and habits that I would,
that I would bring up first,
but I could go on,
I could spend three hours
talking about this. Okay.
A little important to
touch on for a second.
I mean, as you know,
I've been taking that very
seriously for particularly,
particularly last six months or so.
And I received an email
the other day from the, uh,
the teacher that I used for
a transcendental meditation.
And there are many different
types of meditation. I'm curious,
I'm going to ask you about what, how you
format your own meditating in a second.
But there are many different types.
I have my issues,
my likes and dislikes as it relates
to almost all of them, but, uh,
received an email with a link
to an article, uh, in the,
the title is Bridgewater founder Ray Daleo
credits transcendental meditation for
his success.
And for those who don't know,
he's the founder of the world's largest
hedge fund, Bridgewater associates.
They have what, 100 billion
plus under under management,
I think. Um, and his quote,
his quote is meditation more than any
other factor has been the secret to
whatever success I've had, uh, that
that is a hell of an endorsement.
So it's, for me, it's been, uh,
getting over that resistance to what I
perceived as sort of a woo new agey type
thing. Um, and the, uh,
the ability to sort of view it almost
as just a warm bath for the mind.
That where I'm taking a mini
vacation from my own brain in a way,
which may or may not
depending on who you ask,
be the most helpful way to look at it.
But I found that a very,
very kind of useful lens through
which to view it. But how do you,
uh, what, what, uh, if there
is a particular type of,
of meditation you followed,
what is it or how do you
personally meditate? I mean,
what do you think of or not think
of? How long do you do it, et Cetera?
Very simple, contemplative
Buddhist sitting meditation.
Um, or I would focus on my breath. Um,
and you know,
this is when I was a late teenager and
then I started getting involved with Tai
Chi and I started studying East
Asian philosophy very deeply.
And this is where I got increasingly
into moving meditation, which,
which is the most deep practice or the
practice that I've personally done most
deeply Tai Chi for meditation.
I,
so the medics data form
of techy is sort of the,
the essence of the art.
And then the fighting application
is what I was competing in.
And so I spent many years
meditating for five,
six hours a day, three
tight with techy. Um,
today I combine my, my tattoo practice
with sitting meditation again.
Um, well most people when they,
when they enter meditation, what I,
what I suggested, they just practice
very simple sitting meditation.
I'm following the breath and it's a
practice which doesn't have to be very
complex.
They can for example,
just sit either cross legged
or comfortably in a chair
and have their and follow
their breath.
And it's very interesting because they'll
notice after one or two seconds of
their mind starts racing off.
And usually what happens when you have
really driven guys who are trying to
meditate for the first time and
their mind races off, they get those,
they get all pissed off,
angry frustration.
They feel like the failing at meditation.
And one of the most important things
to do is to embrace the fact that
meditation isn't about perfection.
It's about the return to breath.
So when you find your mind racing,
you observe that and you
return to your breath.
And that's a tough emotional
hurdle for a lot of guys.
And it's very interesting because over
time, you know, you know, the metaphor of,
of basically the mind is a,
is a wild stallion that over time your
attainment and you ultimately learn to
still at its racing, it's fucking, it's
pulling against anything. You put it,
you paint kind of line you put on it.
Um,
but ultimately the circles get
smaller and smaller and you,
you learn to observe when your mind is
getting caught up in some kind of mental
or emotional addiction more
and more quickly and fluidly.
And the returning to breath becomes easier
and easier. And it's very interesting,
by the way, as a competitor
because I relate to the theme of,
of channeling and emotion or fear,
whatever is rising it. And you know,
as a world class competitor in very
much the same way we might speak about
meditation. Um, you know, I spoke
at a conference on grid, uh,
recently and it was very interesting
for me because for the most part when I
listened,
resilience trit yeah.
Which is of course core
educational principle and a
lot of charter schools these
days is hugely important.
Teaching kids to be resilient. Um,
and it's very interesting because what,
when I hear people speak
about resilience, um, from,
and this is sort of a, we're moving
a little bit of size of meditation,
but we'll bring it back. Um,
the focus is on, for example,
overcoming difficulty, um,
suffering, learning to,
to basically push through.
What people don't realize is
that world class performers,
what they've done is they've reoriented
their relationship to suffering or that
to the point of versus since
they've learned to embrace it,
they've learned to see the beauty
in these moments where there's pain.
Cause that's incredible room for growth.
And I think that a lot of what you
learned to do in meditation is observe the
addictive way. You might be defining
something. And if you want to,
you can simply alter that definition so
you can change your relationship to pain
or the rain or a huge
storm or fear or anger.
So for example, people from the outside,
we'll use the term fearlessness, right?
But if you speak to any great soldier or
a seal team member or a fighter or UFC
guy, they'll tell you mixed martial law,
right? You know, world class fighters,
they'll tell you that they feel fear.
They just know how to sit with their
fear and how to work with it and how to
channel it.
So the idea of fearlessness is sort of
a false idea which is imposed from the
outside by a spectator.
Um,
and when you observe
world class performers,
what they've learned how to do
is harness fear, nerves, anxiety,
bring them in,
embraced them,
have a working relationship with
them and channel them into intensity.
And Meditation is an
incredible forum or vehicle,
which you can do this because you learn
to observe where you have addictive
relationships and you realize that
they're not absolute and you can actually
transform your relationship
to any of these thought
patterns, thought, Constructs,
cognitive biases,
what emotional patterns.
But it's one of my favorite quotes, who,
boxers like Floyd Patterson,
you know, Jose Torres,
most famously perhaps Mike Tyson.
And he would say to the hero and
the coward both feel the same thing,
but the hero of uses this fear of projects
it onto his opponent while the coward
runs. It's the same thing. Fear, but
it's what you do with it that matters.
And I,
uh,
I started meditating and
gave up meditating many,
many times because I had the,
the response that you mentioned about
type a personalities where I'd be sitting
there and I thought the
objective was to quiet my mind.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
And so when,
so when I failed at quieting my mind
because it would be ticking off the to do
list or being Aiga,
that fucker who said B and c to me the
other day and it was just like harp on
these ridiculous things and I'd get then
pissed and then I'd get pissed that I
was getting pissed and get up and have a
cup of coffee and like storm out of the
house, which didn't seem like a
productive meditation session. Um,
I actually started doing
it consistently when, uh,
I kept it really short and a friend
of mine recommended this where I would
number one be comfortable. So I would, I
would sit down, but to avoid back pain,
I would actually lean against a wall,
which is very commonly
thought of as a big no, no.
So it would lean against a wall to keep
my back straight and I would listen to
one music track. I listened to one song
every morning, the same song as a Q.
And I would just pay attention
to my breath and focus on
being an observer of my
thoughts,
but not trying to control them at all.
So if all I did was think about my to
do list the entire time, that's fine.
As long as I'm paying attention to my
breath and that non attachment to an
outcome I controlling my thoughts
was, was very helpful. And the,
the format that I followed
subsequent to that. Um, and you know,
we can have a longer conversation
about why it finally clicked,
but the short answer is accountability.
I had a teacher who was going to
give me a hard time if I didn't do my
meditating and then report
back, uh, was toy 20 minutes,
let's just say 10 to
20 minutes twice a day.
And when I found was by allowing the
thoughts to occur and not judging myself,
because let's say I'm thinking about
email or the grocery shopping I need to do
or whatever, just letting that happen.
But getting good at observing it,
I was able to then have more
emotional awareness and later,
which would prevent cognitive
biases and bad judgments.
So what I mean by that is, as a concrete
example, uh, I'm a, I'm an impatient guy.
I always have been ever since I was a
little, literally little kid, like 12,
13 years old, if I was at the
restaurant with my mom and dad and,
and the server didn't come over and pour
water after we'd been gone dry for like
five minutes,
I'd just get up and walk into the
kitchen and like grab a picture and walk
lockup. And, uh, I'm really impatient and,
uh,
I get angry.
I get angry about things that I view
as deliberately slow and sloppy.
So for me, uh, and,
and that anger can be harnessed sometimes
and do really productive aggression,
but it's also, it wears
you down and both ends. Um,
and so what I've found is after meditating
consistently for even a week or so,
uh,
when that anger would start,
I was better at not just become,
I was better at observing
Tim as a third person,
right? Like, oh, look at that.
Like Tim's getting angry about
something really small and stupid, uh,
as opposed to simply becoming angry
and then causing problems for myself,
whether it's just internal or interacting
with other people. So, uh, yeah,
I agree with you completely on,
on the meditation and
12 year old racing into the kitchen
and bring up a metaphor for your life.
Let's, let's do a couple of
rapid fire questions that are,
that are all tied into
this, this, this stuff.
But we can just do short questions
with a couple of short answers. Um,
so complete the following statement.
My favorite time of day is blank.
My favorite time of day is holding my son
in my arms after I've done my woken up
within a 20, 30 minutes journaling
session. And I get my son, I can,
I bring him downstairs and I give him
his bottle of milk and I hold them.
And I looked at him in the eye and I
told them how proud I am of them and we
talk about what he's thinking about and
what he's working on. Willie I smell can.
I think it's the most magical
part of my day these days
in the morning.
Okay.
Yeah, that's a, I wake up, I wake
up about half an hour before him.
I do a big creative burst. Um,
this has been, as a parent,
your sleep patterns change
pretty dramatically,
but I found this rhythm where I
wake up and I do that personally.
I just love that first morning energy
Tom with him and we have this deep
connection while he's
having his, um, his milk.
What time do you wake up?
I usually wake up around seven seven
oh five and he's usually wake up around
seven 37 35.
I'm endlessly fascinated by
digging. I'm digging into the
minutia. But when you wake up,
it sounded like you wake up and you have
30 minutes to journal before bringing
your son downstairs. Do you brush
your teeth, drink a cup of coffee,
any of that before you journal
or do you just roll out of bed,
walk into the office
and sit down to write?
I
brush my teeth.
I go downstairs and I sit down with
my journal and I started writing and I
immediately applied myself to two or
reflection that I sort of targeted my mind
at [inaudible] and evening
or late afternoon before. Um,
and then when I, when after and I just
let it rip, I have a big creative search.
Um, and then once I hear my
son, I go get them. And then,
then I have my breakfast,
um, usually, uh, below,
um, while he has his, you know,
after he has his note and then I have a
cup of coffee about half an hour after
that
related to me,
the happy guy.
Obviously we all have our
challenges then and again,
uh,
like a remodeled at the moment.
I won't go into a diatribe at the moment.
I'm very excited about it, but it's my,
uh,
you know,
a 12 year old Tim wanting to go get the
water pitchers is not being very helpful
right now. The, what are three things?
It can be two or three things that you
believe you need in order to be happy.
And that can be for you. Uh, it could be
for people in general. I'm just curious.
Uh, what, how you would think of that
question or answer that question.
Okay.
Being different and having
these conversations is that
you tend to be very good
at thinking and bullets.
I can tell you the
essence of how I really,
I'm not going to give you three
bullet answer cause I just,
that's just not how this brain operates.
Built a lifestyle around
being true to myself. Largely.
Maybe a big reason is because of,
you know,
my mom used to always tell me as a kid
to follow my heart, follow my dreams. Um,
I never made decisions for money
or for external things. Um,
and it was trusted. If I was true to
myself, these things would follow. And so,
you know, my professional
life, my foundation, my school,
I only work with people who I feel are
ethically aligned to have a good energy,
who I feel really good about intuitively.
Um,
I keep empty space in my life.
I rarely have more than one
or two meetings a day. Um,
my life is about quality and not quantity
and it's about depth and not breadth.
Um,
I businesses based on doing very,
very deep and very a excellent work,
work with just a handful of people.
And so I really liked to cultivate
quality as a way of life.
And I believe that when you're
not cultivating quality,
you're essentially cultivating
sloppiness. And so, you know,
the idea of building the musculature of
quality and being like a heat seeking
missile form.
And I take great pleasure in observing
the beauty of the little moments in life.
Um, and so for me, my lifestyle is based
on, you know, I'm working out every day.
I just focused on structured and data
will allow for my creative process to be
rich. I'm present with my son.
I have my office is at home,
I'm with them in the morning, I'm with
him, I see him throughout the day.
I'm with him, give him his bath
and read them a story. And I,
and with them I've eliminated almost
all travel. That takes me away. Um,
from, from my boy going to
a conference this weekend,
I'm taking my wife and my baby
are coming with me. Um, and I,
I really build a life around being true
and I don't build it around anything
material.
And that's really the essence of how
I personally relate to this question.
Of course there's different
solutions for everybody, but um,
works for me.
I think it's a goal that most people
have at least in the abstract.
But I'd love to dig into
some concrete details of that.
Perhaps you could share
an example of something you changed,
like maybe where you got slightly off
the path and made a correction to be true
to yourself and what that looked like.
A very clear example is my public life.
So I was a young kid,
fell in love with chess when I was,
I won my first national championship
when I was a lead eight, early nine.
Um, when I was 11, a book came
out searching for I Fisher. Um,
and then when I was 15 movie came out
about my life based on the same book that
my dad initially wrote. And
so I was really thrust into
the spotlight. And so I,
you know, without me wanting
to, I was just, you know, a
young, passionate artist.
I love playing chess
and competing and chest.
I was put out there and I had Paparazzi
following me everywhere. I was, um,
you know, I was really living in the, in,
in the spotlight in a way I wasn't
necessarily emotionally prepared for.
And I felt in my teens how that challenged
my love for this art cause my love
for it was so pure initially. Um, and,
and that tension, you know, that that
fight, that fight to stay true to my art,
um,
taught me some very deep lessons.
And then I know after
I finished high school,
I took off and I left the
country largely to study chess.
Very deeply undistracted from publicity.
I moved to Eastern Europe. Um,
my girlfriend at the time
was from Slovenia. Um,
no one knew me out there and it was a
beautiful life and I just left the public
world. And since then have,
you know, when I came back,
I've had these periods where I've been
exposed to publicity and I've been
periods where I've been deep in the
cave and moved away from it. And,
and I think that this is a very clean
example of, I mean, other than you
drag me out,
you have a way of doing that to me,
but in a beautiful way. And I mean, I,
I've found that the privacy of my life,
I'm not doing things,
not getting caught up in,
in the swirl of fame or seeking external
adulation is a very important thing for
me personally. Everyone's different.
But, but for me, I mean, I am amazed,
maybe I have a little bit of
a, um, an over sensitivity
to this because of, of my,
my youth, because I was out there so
intensely as a young, as a young guy.
And I think it really challenged
my love for the game. Um,
and this is an example of the kind
of decision that I'll make. I mean,
I think it's very important for me to,
to,
to live the vast majority
of my life privately.
I don't do very much that will allow
me to be recognized in the street and
living my life as a celebrity because
I've gone down that path and I,
I love my prophecy.
Um,
and I also have built a career around my
business is working with people who are
similar,
who are not seeking the limelight,
who are not out there on television
every day, who are world class, but her,
no one around them. Um, other
than people, you know, very close,
had any idea that they have been so
incredibly successful from a monetary way.
They try to raise their kids,
um, not to be spoiled. Um,
the kids are gritty kids there,
you know, great philanthropists,
um, really good people.
And you know, I love,
I'm very drawn to people who have
been enormous to successful, um,
but don't get caught up in the external
crap that comes with success and a real,
you know, who were living their
life, tapped into the love. Um,
and that's how I try to lift.
What are the books
either most gifted to other people
or most recommended to other people.
Uh, because there are many people
listening to this probably who
won't necessarily have the opportunity
to interact with the types of,
of high level folks, uh, that,
that you and I are so fortunate to
have the chance to interact with,
but they can do that. Visa
the books or narratives, uh,
documentaries,
et cetera.
What are some books that have
had a formative impact on you?
A huge impact on my life,
on the road, Dharma bums.
His books were initially kind of taps
me into the idea that life could be
ecstatically beautiful. And
I moved into studying, um,
that wasn't so loud to the
Dao de Jing. Hugely. Um,
just unbelievably deep for the course of
translation of that book that you read
will be formative.
And I,
my favorite translation is the GF who
sang and Jane English translation of the
diversion, um, Zen and the
art of motorcycle maintenance.
I think one of the most important books
ever written by Robert Person who has
become a very dear friend over
the years. He, he, he, when my,
when the order of learning came
out and my publisher asked me,
who would you love to read
this book? And I said, well,
the one person that really want to
read that book is, um, Robert Person.
And to me that it was just, you know, he,
he lived like a deeply secluded life.
Um,
but they somehow manage to
get them a copy of the book.
He got an a big Bushel from his publisher
and he read it and he contacted me and
wrote, I mean, I was so honored that he,
that he was moved by it. And he and I,
and over the years it developed
really interesting dialogue. Um,
is that his motorcycle maintenance is one,
I think one of the most important books
in the world. The focus on quality,
dynamic, quality, um,
finding art in learning the
fine art in anything equally,
deeply brilliant. Um,
philosophical book. Um,
shanter on one of the most
beautiful novels I have. I
never had Gregory Roberts.
Also someone I've gotten to know very
well. Um, just to ecstatically beautiful,
beautiful book. And you know, of course
I'm also a lover of fiction. I mean,
Hemingway has been, he's probably the
most important writer of my life. Um,
almost everything of his effort.
Any particular novel stand out for you?
I mean,
I think that for whom the bell tolls,
just exquisite novel of Green
Hills of Africa. Amazing. Um,
his short stories are utterly magnificent.
Um,
I think green hills of
Africa is one of the most,
is one of the most underrated
books that he's written.
His is complete collection
of short stories.
I mean there's one magnificent
gem after the next, um,
of course old man and the sea is,
everyone thinks about and beautiful book.
Um, I guess if I had to have
a favorite, it would be,
it would be for whom the bell tolls
insight into his writing style.
Uh,
a moveable feast is okay.
Magnificent book. Yeah. Yeah. Also
really speaks to his writing process.
So fascinating. Uh, there's a
great book, by the way, Tim,
I think you've read
Hemingway and writing this book. I
did read it. I also read that, yeah,
you want it. If someone was just
get to know a Hemingway to do,
it's just a fantastic compilation of all
of Hemingway's writing and letters in
his books, in his articles everywhere. Um,
put together thematically basically
Hemingway on the writing process.
I think it's one of the most important
little collections of, of um,
on creativity that I've ever run into.
Absolutely brilliant.
I remember I read it,
read it on kindle on a short flight
that I had and just like jammed right
through the whole thing.
The uh,
one of the recommendations was
write drunk,
edit sober and I realized that write
drunk edit sober does not translate to
podcasts very well. The last podcast
that I did with a buddy Kevin Rose,
if you record drunk and
tried to edit sober,
it doesn't really
actually work the same way
a man.
What a,
and we'll just do a couple more
questions because this has been fun. The,
but if you had to run out of your house
and just take a handful of things with
you, obviously your family is safe
so that that's accounted for. Uh,
what would you take and why
and what kind of situation
in a very dangerous tuition
you don't have to fend for yourself with,
with weaponry or,
or create fire with Flint or
anything like that. Um, there's a,
there's a fire in your house,
you just have to get out to the street
and then you're going to obviously sort
things out later, but assuming your
family is safe, uh, what would you,
what would you take with you?
You just what you can carry basically.
Yeah.
How crazy it was. I
was, um, there was, uh,
I was studying chess with his brilliant
Russian grand masters [inaudible] who
actually wrote about my book. And
there was a, I was in the fifth,
fifth floor of a walkup through the old
one bedroom. I had my first apartment.
And um,
and there was something that we were deep
deep into chest study and there was a
huge fire.
I looked at,
there were like five fire engines and
dude screaming at us and we had it,
did it go out the fire escape.
And I ended up going back in and grabbing
my computer with all my chest analysis,
which is just a random thing.
Yeah. And it ended up being, we had been
seconds from being an updraft in bloom,
the whole building on, um,
yeah. So I wouldn't do that.
Think
honestly,
when you asked me the question now
I think that my family was safe.
I have nothing material that I would,
that I would grab.
Uh, all right. I'm going
to ask you one more,
uh, actually in, I'll give
you a choice of two questions.
So the first option is what did
you want to be when you grew up,
when you were a kid,
and now how would you answer the question?
What do you want to be when you grow
up? That's, that's question one.
Question number two is if
you had a committee of three
people living or dead to
help you make decisions,
who would you choose and why?
These are great questions,
man.
Thanks. Um, by, by the way,
I'm borrowing liberally from like every
good interviewer I've ever come in
contact. But, so it goes
and we answer them. Both of you
have an answer, one of them, uh,
you can answer very different
questions. I mean, this is tough man.
Yeah. I mean if they, if they, uh, I'm
just trying to be respectful of your time,
but if you have time and you have
some thoughts on both, let's, let's,
let's go for it.
When I grew up, when I was a kid, I wanted
to be a professional baseball player.
I just love, I love them. So
there's something about sports. Um,
so I think that there was a, I'm going
to, and I spend a lot of my life as a,
as a competitor from age
basically six until you know,
35. I was basically a
professional competitor field,
um,
today and about,
my mom always said to me that she felt
like that was the phase and that I was a
healer.
I was holding her language.
And a lot of what I do today is try to
figure out how to help people express
themselves in is pure way as possible
artistically in a way that gives them joy.
I mean,
I think that my plan is sometime in the
next four or five years now I'm 37 now.
I'm thinking about it when I'm 40, 41. Um,
I guess that'd be three, four years now.
Yep.
Turn my mind to everything.
Taking everything I've been doing in
these different laboratories and apply it
to a, a world changing education
initiative. Um, helping children in, uh,
just fulfill themselves
in a very deep way,
I think is a central
column, which I'm, that's,
that's I'm not going to say is my
end game, but that's the next, um,
major chapter I think of my life that
I'm building towards and running my
foundation for for many years now.
And we do beautiful work,
but I have an allergy to scaling if
it's going to dilute quality in any way.
And so I've been sort of
building up the foundation,
the ground work to ultimately be able to,
to do something hugely
important in education.
So I think that that's going to be, um,
the core of how I would, I would, um,
I'm building towards that in a few years.
Um,
in terms of the committee of three people
to interject for a second,
that's also,
I think my calling and of course
we've spoken at length about this.
So if you need a coconspirator
count me in for that one. Certainly
years
sounds like a plan.
Taps that movement away from
self as a competitor. You're,
you're constantly, you're fighting and
in many ways you're, you know, you're,
there's something about the
focus inward on oneself and I,
and becoming a paradigm. I've
definitely felt this movement. Um,
it's away from that. I mean, my,
my son is just my love for him,
so transcend anything I ever, I
ever felt before. It's been really,
really important to experience
when you become a dad man,
then we're going to have some fun.
What would you have sleepless nights?
Oh Man.
You're going to see,
what are your thoughts?
Well, one person who would be on
that committee as someone who,
um, who I know very, very deep friend
of mine who happens to be in the,
in the finance world,
I can't speak about his last
name is deeply meditative spirit,
great wisdom, um, as insightful human
beings I've ever known in my life.
And I think that that he would
definitely be on, um, on that list.
Um, I mean, can we go,
can we go into kick?
Can I say outrageous?
There's like, like Gandhi.
Yeah,
I mean I think of that
Gandhi loud,
the Buddha. I mean, my God, what, what,
what am but if she needs
to be is a certain,
yeah. I don't know, man. I don't
know if I can answer this question.
Very intelligent. Like
you could put it, yeah.
I don't know. And Tim, of
course you, man, you give me,
you give me so much crap in life
you because you'd be the one just to,
just to keep,
definitely be wanting displays through
all the nonsense yet. And my mom,
that's the most important one. My
mom, she has given me the most, um,
deep advice in my life.
I mean,
my mom is the one person who has really
embraced these crazy decisions that I've
made when I've left arts,
when I was at the tops of their field.
If those fields and because of some
strange calling ahead inside, I think, um,
no, I'm gonna have to do the top of
any of us like that. She's my hero.
I'm the greatest person
if your normal life,
awesome
conversations. Uh, is there anything
you want to, any parting thoughts,
advice, suggestions, anything like
that, the, that you'd like to impart?
If not, we can, we can, we can call
it a day. But, uh, the mic is yours.
If you have anything you'd like to add.
Well,
one thing that I've been doing
in the last years, um, after,
since writing the amount of learning
is I've been exposed to know the most
brilliant thinkers and these
different fields. Um, and I've,
I've studied the patterns behind them and
I've studied the people who study them.
And one of the things we have to
be wary of in life is studying the,
the people who study the artist as
opposed to the artists themselves. Um,
person who the other of them, they are the
most cycle maintenance. As I mentioned.
He uses this great term, the philosophers
and the full philosophy ologists right?
That's a lot of colleges are the ones who
are basically philosophizing about the
philosophers as supposed
to do in philosophy.
And the vast majority philosophers today
actually are just philosophy ologists
similarly, these, you know,
you don't have to discuss,
there's the writers and
his literary critic.
There's the artist and the art critic.
And I think that we have
to be very careful when we,
when we study excellence
and we're thinking about our
own path to excellence, um,
that we're studying the,
then we're tuning into the direct
experience of people who've actually been
there as opposed to the arms. You have
professors who were talking about it,
right? Because you know, it,
if we spend our life in the trenches
and we spend our life studying that last
like 0.1% of the learning process,
what we see is that,
that that final passage to excellence
is really about navigating that razor's
edge where you have to be willing to go
right up against a potential enormous
blender. And you have to
improvise, for example,
trust your intuition and moments
where all of the objective, um,
mathematical faculties you've
developed a telling you something else,
but your intuition is operating
at a higher level. Um,
you have to really be willing to
go up to the brink of disaster,
um, to, to succeed in moments
where you're, for example,
fighting in the finals of
a world championship or in
the very last second of the
Superbowl or an NBA finals. And,
and in navigating these things,
the arms, your professors will often
have the exact opposite of good advice,
right? And so, so what I would say
is, is for one thing, you know,
listen deeply internally to, to the core
of your being and build your game plan.
From there, it trust your gut.
And then build a lifestyle
around listening to that
and cultivate the love.
And that's the other thing I'd say is
that whether you're talking about at the
beginning of the learning process
or that were the very, you know,
the very final surge or surges,
it's about the love and we're thinking
about parenting and cultivating
resilience because of any
excellence called the van.
Creativity with the armature professors
all forget about is the love.
Um,
and that's what I see consistently with
people who have found the most pleasure,
the most happiness,
um,
and created the greatest start is that
they have a profound passion for what
they do. Not only the big
moments but the little moments,
but the moments that others would call
pain. They learned to love practice.
They learned to love the point
of resistance. Um, I said,
don't forget about the love.
I guess that's what I'd like to say.
I'm sure we will be talking next time.
We'll have some wine
and I hope everybody checks out.
Obviously the art of learning and really
keeps an eye on what you have come in
when you decide to push
stuff out of the cave.
Do you want more of the Tim Ferriss show?
You can subscribe to the podcast
on iTunes or go to for our blog.com
where you'll find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park,
the books plus much, much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com slash
t Ferris that's top or on Facebook at
facebook.com/tim Ferris. Until
next time, thanks for listening.